i'm going to say
i've never written a first draft that
was perfect and you're going to say why
okay okay and then i'll give you the
answer sure that i give my students okay
i've never written a first draft that
was perfect
so anyway i you know
i've said this to my students and
they're always surprised because
everyone has this notion that sometimes
you just
write something and it's
perfect as soon as you write it it
happens
everyone assumes that happens that
everybody gets lucky sometime and i said
to them i have never written
something in a first draft that was
perfect
that never had to have any changes
and what do they say to that no you will
say why is that oh that's right okay
sorry whose line is it um
why do they say that
no why is that oh sorry okay let me try
that again
why is that this is funny this is a j
this is a funny joke
uh the way you
okay
um let me try sorry let's
why is that well wait no let's see a
little digression here okay so you're
going to interview me okay okay and uh
make sure you speak loud so they can
hear you sure you have to say
i understand you're the world's greatest
comedian
okay uh mr grapes i understand that you
are the world's greatest comedian
and i say yes
then you say to what do you attribute
your great success let me hear it to
what do you do
sorry you're going to say yes or no to
what do you attribute right but you're
going to say right yeah yes okay to what
do you attribute your great success good
let's just rehearse that one let's do it
and then we'll do it for the camera okay
okay all right uh start okay
you are the world's greatest comedian mr
grapes no it's i understand oh okay
you got to get the lines exactly right
sure mr graves mr grapes thank you for
taking my question uh karen with film
courage i understand you are the world's
greatest comedian yes okay to
to what do you attribute that successor
no to what do you attribute your great
success okay to what do you
to what do you attribute your great
success sir great are you are you ready
to shoot it oh i thought we already were
no we we were rehearsing right now okay
okay sorry no i mean i know he's running
it but right right okay this is the joke
okay sure sure so have you got it down
have you got your line yeah i think so i
think so okay okay
um mr graves thank you for taking my
question karen with film courage
i understand you're the world's greatest
comedian yes
to what do you timing
okay
there you go
you get it i do yeah uh-huh okay
so
um
um i'm gonna say
i've never written a first draft that
was perfect and you're gonna say
why okay okay and then i'll give you the
answer sure that i give my students okay
i've never written a first draft that
was perfect
why
because i'm too good for that
okay now what does that mean
oh
many that's the thing because they're
not expecting that they think that if
you write a first draft it means you're
good and i said i never get a perfect
first draft because i'm too good for
that
that flips it on its head they're going
too good you mean if you're too good
all your first drafts are not good i
would think that if you're good your
first some of your first drafts might be
really good but you're saying
i'm too good to have a perfect first
draft
why do you think that would be
oh um
modesty
nope i just said i'm too good for that
okay
um
delusion
what delusion
the the what delusion delusional no no
i i i wrote it and i go this is not
perfect and i've never had a perfect
first drive i see um i don't know
because
i can see
where it can be improved
and the person who's not that good
doesn't see where it can be improved
but i'm good
i'm too good
to have a perfect first draft because i
can see
where it can be better
that's half the answer
the other half of the answer is
and i know how to make it better
because sometimes you can go
um this first draft it's
not quite
perfect i know it needs to be fixed but
i don't know how
what i'm saying is i'm too good for that
because one i can always see how
anything can be made better and two i
know how to do it
so that dispels that notion that a lot
of people have that if you really know
what you're doing you should be able to
write that first draft and it's perfect
and i'm saying
well
no
because if you're really good you will
always see how something can be made
better
and
you have the tools
and the knowledge to make it better you
know how to do it
so again that to me is a little paradox
which i kind of like because hopefully
what i'm saying to my students is
don't
think
that the first draft of anything you
write is going to be perfect
because if you are really good
you will see that it can be better
and
if you know how to make it better that's
that's that's
that's what you want
you want to be able to go hmm this thing
is not perfect but if i do this this
this and this
it'll be perfect
and so at what point does someone know
where the weaknesses are
at what point do they know where the
weaknesses are or at what point do they
get to where they go
well it's not perfect but
i'm done the latter
there's a famous saying that poets never
finish writing a poem they only abandon
it
that at some point you might still feel
well it's not perfect but
enough is enough i got to move on to my
next one
you know so um
maybe there's always going to be a point
where you think well this is as good as
i can make it and you you go on
i mean
i don't think you can say to someone
uh
there's a point where you will always
know where you can make it better and i
mean you know we're human beings
sometimes what we send out is imperfect
and
sometimes we got to go well
that's enough you know i got to move on
to the next thing
this is not the best soup i ever made
but it'll do
uh you know there's an old saying
writing is rewriting
so
first drafts are usually
that's all their first drafts
um
i've never written anything
that didn't go through more than one
draft
i in other words i've never written
anything that was perfect
the first time out
now you're supposed to ask me why